to play Devil's Advocate what would you
say to women or or men that say oh well
what about a guy that has a high Notch
count
um there's some evidence that suggests
that guys that have banged a lot of
women
um have a harder time
um being monogamous to
you know their wife you know for example
but that's a topic of commitment versus
monogamy so if you've got a guy that's
banged like 200 girls you know before he
got married and he gets married there's
a higher chance that the guy with a 200
Notch count is going to go outside of
that marriage and uh cheat versus the
guy that's only been with like one gal
you know for example now that doesn't
mean that he's going to leave the
marriage all that means is he might go
out and get some exercise from time to
time and come back and still alive his
wife and his kids and pay the mortgage
and do the family events and all that
stuff right
um so yeah there's that but the
difference between men and women is that
it has more effect on women like being
with more guys has more of a detrimental
effect on women one and two
um it's also more likely that they'll
leave the relationship whereas guys see
when men and women cheat they cheat for
different reasons right like when men
cheat
um it's really just to like we're here
to scatter seed you know like that's why
we make millions of sperm every single
month and women make one egg right when
women cheat it's usually because they
want to Monkey Branch out to another
relationship and they're looking for a
secure way to leave guy a and go to guy
B you know sort of thing it's usually
because they're done whereas I've seen
loads and loads of guys cheat on their
wives for years they'll be traveling
they do conferences or airline pilots or
entrepreneurs I run multiple businesses
in different cities and they go outside
of the marriage their wife just sort of
looks the other way and then he comes
back home and make sure that you know
like everybody's taking care of he loves
his wife as a kid and all that sort of
thing but you know from time to time he
looks for some excitement so it's a
different thing you know when it comes
to that it's it's more dangerous for men
as well too because if you get a woman
you know in your house and in your life
and you start a family with her and
she's more apt to leave if things don't
go well well she's probably going to
lead with half your [__] she's probably
going to leave with your kids you might
only see them like 20 of the time or 10
percent of time as most guys get you
know parenting rights to their kids at
that point in time which is a lot more
dangerous for men because there's more
at risk for men when it comes to
marriage than it is for women because
women only marry across and up on the
socioeconomic scale they never usually
marry down most women marry more
successful men so Kevin from the
accounting department let's make a
quarter million dollars a year will
often marry the uh hairdresser that's
making forty thousand dollars a year so
there's no real risk to her in that
marriage you know if he cheats but if
she wants to leave he's [__] right so
is it is it going to affect men sure but
it doesn't affect them the same way that
affects women and the damage to men
isn't the same as it is to women I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out